[Music]
6200 square feet three bedrooms three
and a half baths
thirty thousand blocks used
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to one of the most unusual and
most celebrated houses in the United
States this is the Annie's house it was
designed and built in 1924 by legendary
and amazing American architect Frank
Lloyd Wright Frank Lloyd Wright ended up
designing for textile block houses in LA
but this one was its most ambitious each
block of the house was cast by hand made
of gravel granite and sand from the site
and actually there's a quote by Frank
Lloyd Wright the says concrete block the
cheapest and ugliest thing in the
building world it lived mostly in the
architectural gutter why not see what
could be done with that cutter Draft
[Music]
some of you might be thinking this house
feels very familiar and that's because
it's being used as a backdrop for movies
TV shows and fashion shoots female House
of the Haunted Hill day of the locust
and of course Ridley Scott's Blade
Runner
[Music]
back in the 20s la was a boomtown
their neighborhoods today where almost
every style of housing is represented in
LA anything goes but there's nothing
quite like this one architecture critic
once said that this house was better
suited for a Mayan God than for an
American family but an American family
did live here Charles Inez and his wife
Mabel they used to own a men's clothing
store in downtown LA they were the ones
who commissioned the house in 2005 the
house was actually on a list of the most
endangered historic places they run
Buerkle a champion of great designer
architecture came to the rescue and
after four years of renovations the
Eddie's house has never looked better
Frank Lloyd Wright wrote to the Ennis
the result is going to stand on that
hill a hundred years or more
long after we're all gone pilgrimages
will be made to it by lovers of the
beautiful from everywhere
you
you
[Music]